how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to the channel as it stands
right now in the MCU there are
technically no Avengers the Avengers as
a team right now is no more Avengers in
game was the highest-grossing film not
just out of all the Marvel movies but
the highest-grossing film of all time
and in that movie we said goodbye to
many of our favorite Avengers and that
left open many spots for the new
Avengers team now given the face for
slate that was revealed in all of the
movies that we have coming up Thor love
and thunder Doctor Strange and the
multiverse of madness the one division
series etc and based off of everything
that we know about phase 5 we can pretty
much determine what the new Avengers
team is going to be of course Marvel
will throw in some outliers and new
people but for the most part we know the
lineup and now it appears that when the
Avengers finally do come back together
and unite to fight one villain we
apparently know who that villain is
going to be and that villain the villain
of the next Avengers film is going to be
Kang the Conqueror
and we have learned quite a bit on how
Kang is going to be introduced into the
MCU as well as the effect that he's
going to have on the future of the MCU
and some specific characters and having
Kang's show up to be the next villain
after avengers endgame and afterthe anos
was seemingly the plan the whole entire
time so in this video I'll break down
three things one is the report that Kang
is going to be introduced into the MCU
and how and when two is how the MCU has
actually built up Kang's introduction
through Avengers in game and three what
effect his introduction will have for
the future of the MCU if you're new be
sure to subscribe to stay up to date on
all things related to the MCU and I'm
still giving away an xbox one and ps4
all you have to do to enter subscribe
notifications turned on like this video
and comment below with your thoughts and
favorite superhero or villain I'm
picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers now when it
comes to the next few phases of the MCU
we know that Galactus and Doctor Doom
are said to be the next big bats but
much like Thanos was built up Galactus
and Doctor Doom are going to have to be
built up as well feyo's took ten years
to build up until he officially made his
appearance in the MCU the same thing is
going to happen for Galactus and Doctor
Doom so there's definitely going to be
villains in between we had Loki in the
first Avengers film and then we had
Ultron in age of Ultron so for the next
Avengers film there's going to be a
villain that isn't
lactis or dr. doom according to reports
it's going to be Kang the Conqueror and
according to said reports he is going to
be introduced in the Loki series I'm
gonna burn this place to the ground now
according to the Loki teaser that we got
that was part of the three-part teaser
that Disney Plus released are in the
Super Bowl Loki is going to run into the
TVA the time variants authority the time
variance Authority is responsible for
keeping timelines in different realities
in check when one timeline or when one
person in a certain time line starts to
affect other universes and other
timelines and threatens them it is the
responsibility of the time variance
authority to eliminate this individual
or even eliminate the timeline so we
clearly know that Loki is going to be
jumping around different timelines
that's why he's in the custody of the
TVA and there's another person that the
TVA has run into many different times
and that is Kang the Conqueror and his
armies now we know the Loki series is
going to directly tie into the MCU films
and according to Daniel Richmond or
Daniel RPK Loki is going to introduce
Kang the Conqueror King is originally
from thousands of years in the future
the 31st century to be exact
originally appearing in Fantastic Four
number 19 in 1963 King is a scholar who
becomes fascinated with time-travel
mostly due to the fact that one of his
ancestors is Reed Richards mr. fantastic
of the Fantastic Four
before deeming him self Kang the
Conqueror his real name was Nathaniel
Richards and Nathaniel ends up stumbling
across a time travel device he uses the
device to go back in time to ancient
Egypt there he dubs himself Pharaoh Rama
Tut and he ends up being defeated by a
time-traveling Fantastic Four in his
defeat he seeks revenge on the Fantastic
Four and he gathers together a wide
array of time travel technology and
weaponry and seeks out to conquer the
multiverse deeming himself Kang the
Conqueror for a full breakdown on Kang's
full story you can check out a video I
did and the link up above so Kang is
clearly associated with time travel in a
very big way which makes the Loki series
a perfect time to officially introduce
Kang into the MCU Loki is going to be
jumping through multiple different
points in time throughout the series and
the TVA is going to be looking for him
and apparently they capture him and a
- Daniel rpk the TVA is also going to
run into King this is something that has
happened to many different times in the
comics however the TVA weren't exactly
successful at stopping King because
they're not really that good at their
job which means Loki is most likely
going to escape as well so loki and kang
could even end up teaming up so the Loki
series according to Daniel RBK is when
King will officially be introduced
however we could see King the conquer in
the MCU a little bit earlier he could
show up in the Eternals now not much is
really known about the plot of the
Eternals however we do know a few big
details and one of these major details
is that on the set of the Eternals they
are building Ishtar's a gate which is
the north entrance to the city of
babylon now babylon existed in the same
time of ancient Egypt and as I mentioned
Kang was Rama Tut the Pharaoh of ancient
Egypt for a long time so it is very
possible that while the Eternals are in
ancient Egypt we could see a pharaoh by
the name of Rama Tut aka King and this
could be his very first appearance and
set up in the MCU if this happens that
means we're going to see came to conquer
in the MCU for the very first time this
year 2020 on November 6th now how does
came to conquer tie into the MCU as it
currently stands well as it turns out
avengers endgame set up king the
conquerors debut perfectly avengers
endgame had a very specific type of time
travel the time travel rules that
avengers in-game abide by are the same
rules that king the conquerors
time-travel abides by and that is a
multiverse or infinite alternate
universes time travel a time travel and
where as the hulk explained it if you
change the past it doesn't affect the
future it simply creates an alternate
timeline so one connection is already
there the avengers use the same type of
time-travel that Kang the Conqueror uses
and if you recall and Avengers in game
Tony Stark's set it himself
you messed with time it tends to mess
back and then we have Loki he escaped
with the tesseract which immediately
created an alternate timeline another
connection and then there's the fact
that Kang is basically the king of
time-travel
there are many multiple versions of Kang
in different realities and Kang travels
throughout time conquering different
realities and the Avengers probably
messed up his plan a little bit
in fact Loki escaping with the tesseract
alone could probably put a halt in some
of
plans not to mention Tony Stark took the
tesseract from camp Lehi in 1970 when
him and Captain America went back in
time another change in history that
could somehow have gotten in the way of
some McCain's plans so King at some
point will most likely catch on to what
the Avengers have done and he'll want to
undo it and he'll also want to take out
the Avengers so they can't do it again
but if we dive into King's backstory we
can see how King arriving will also set
the arrival for some other characters to
enter the MCU as I mentioned in the
beginning Kang's ancestor is Reed
Richards mr. fantastic of the Fantastic
Four however at one point in time there
was a comic that changed this and said
he was an ancestor of Doctor Doom now
Doctor Doom has been reported to be one
of the next big bad villains so King
coming in to be the villain for Avengers
five in the MCU could set up the arrival
of Doctor Doom and the Fantastic Four
and it works the other way around - if
he's an ancestor of Reed Richards that
introduces the Fantastic Four
therefore introducing Doctor Doom now
the setup for the Fantastic Four is very
very likely Avengers five and Kang's
debut will most likely be at the end of
phase 5 or in phase 6 this is around the
exact same time that the Fantastic Four
are suspected to make their debut in the
MCU we know that they're going to be
coming before the x-men because Kevin
Feige has mentioned this before in the
past and Kevin Feige did name drop them
at San Diego comic-con in 2019 which
means they are coming relatively soon
this means that the Avengers could work
with the Fantastic Four to take on king
or the Fantastic Four could be brought
in right after Avengers 5 and then after
Avengers 5 there is something else that
Kang sets up the Young Avengers there is
a version of Kang a young version of
Nathaniel Richards who goes on to become
iron lad however the young Nathaniel
Richards does not align himself with
Kang the Conqueror and instead he sort
of becomes the next Iron Man he becomes
iron lad any forms of The Young Avengers
and from there they fight King now if
you look at everything that's happened
in the MCU recently The Young Avengers
have been set up quite obviously we have
Kate Bishop coming to the MCU to take on
the mantle of Hawkeye Cassie Lang Scott
Lang's daughter is set up to be stature
and then you have Wiccan and speed the
twin boys of Wanda and vision and
they're already confirmed to be coming
to the MC
based off of the trailers that we gotten
for one a vision but then you have
Harley keener the little boy from Iron
Man 3 as you probably know he was at
Tony Stark's funeral at the end of
Avengers endgame now Marvel does
everything for a reason and it seems
like there was a bigger purpose for
Harley being at the funeral for Tony
Stark especially since we haven't heard
from him since Iron Man 3 it's widely
anticipated that he is going to go on to
become iron lad so it seems like the MCU
may tweak just a little bit his name but
Harley keiner could be a future king the
Conqueror and Harley Kiner could go on
to find this out take up the mantle of
Iron Man becoming iron lad and formed
the Young Avengers the younger ventures
are already confirmed to be coming to
the MCU at some point in time and we
know that they're not going to replace
Iron Man anytime soon so the next best
thing is I and lad this will commemorate
Iron Man but it won't replace him as to
make his death less meaningful instead
it will be in memory of him but iron
lads future is to become Kang the
Conqueror and eventually he does end up
becoming King even after defeating King
he realizes that the only way for
everybody to survive is for him to
eventually accept his fate so he ends up
becoming Kang the Conqueror and this is
where the future of the MCU is heading
according to Daniel RPK Kang the
Conqueror is going to be introduced in
the Loki series and from there we'll see
him become a major villain let me know
what you think about Kang's debut in the
comments down below don't forget to give
this video a like and subscribe and
notifications turned on to stay up to
date on everything relating to the MCU
and so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or ps4 I'm
picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof